-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Laura Dern.
It's such a fantastic book.
There's so many great stories.
Are there any anecdotes
that stand out for you
that you were really excited
to be able to put on the page
after you heard them
from your mother?
-I mean, all of my mother's
childhood stories,
again, things I never knew,
stories I had never heard.
But my godmother was the amazing
actress Shelley Winters,
and a lot of their wild rides
are in the book.
I won't spoil them.
There are a few
that aren't in the book,
but hearing
all of their stories --
I remember my mom telling me
this one story of Shelley
had gained weight
and she was like,
"We've got to go to a spa,
and we've got to lose weight."
And my mother was like,
[sighs]
Like, "I don't want to really go
or lose weight."
She's like,
"Well, you're coming with me.
I need you. I need your support.
We're going to go to this place
and we're going to go
to this weight loss clinic
and it's going
to be incredible."
And she had this like, old
vintage convertible Cadillac,
and they drove to this place
out in the desert.
And it was, I think,
the second night my mom
hears, like, a ferocious
knock at her door
and she says,
"I'm starving to death.
You've got to get me
out of here."
And and my mother was like, "No,
this is a five-day program."
And so she said,
"Just meet me in five minutes
in the parking lot."
And she had put her car
in neutral and made my mom
and she push it carefully
out of the parking lot.
They went for burgers and pizza,
and then came back
the next morning,
and someone was like,
"I've got to say,
I've had a smoothie
and I'm starving."
My mom's like, "Really?
I feel fine."
This is -- you know.
-At least she got her exercise
in pushing a car.
-Exactly.
Probably break even
at some level.
-I'm just going to start
doing that and not go.
-This is very fun.
You get to go on a book tour
and basically road trip
with your mom.
This is the gift
that keeps giving.
-It's incredible.
It's incredible.
We are here together
in New York City doing press.
And I mean, this is her city
because she loves being
a theater actress as well.
So we're having so much fun
and we're going to Nashville,
San Francisco, New Orleans.
I mean, it's going to be great.
-The whole thing
is is really exciting.
And one thing, you know, I
felt -- I was saying backstage,
this made me feel like
I should have more conversations
like this with my mother,
because I think ultimately,
you read this,
and I feel like people who maybe
miss that chance wonder
why they never asked
these things. Because I do think
that once you get past
the hurdle of asking them,
everybody wants
to tell their story.
And is that part of it,
not just to read the stories
about your mother/daughter
relationship,
but sort of encourage everybody
to connect with a parent?
-It's the only reason
we're sharing,
is because I watched my mom,
who I was sure was going
to leave a few years ago,
still be here.
I have actual concrete proof
that communicating and loving
each other in this way,
having these conversations
are going to do
so much for everyone.
And so we said,
"Let's just share it."
If it impacts one person --
and we just met someone today
who's a friend who shared
the story
of going to see his grandmother,
who's very religious,
and as a gay man,
he was thinking of not
sharing with her
and coming out to her
about his life.
And he thought -- he said,
"I read the book
and I chose to share
with my grandmother."
And it was so healing
and so incredible
and her response
was so loving and beautiful.
And so my mom was like,
"See?
See? That's the one person."
I was like,
"Well, hopefully there's a few
more that also connect to it."
But it's for everybody.
Friends who are siblings said,
"My God, we've never
asked each other,
'How are you doing?
Are you okay?'"
And I think for me,
one of the great lessons
was I didn't want to
bring up anything
that might wound her more.
But everything
we talked through,
even some of her hardest
heartbreaks as we get into here,
she felt that she got
healthier and healthier
by just releasing certain things
that she'd never talked about.
-Well, it's just really lovely.
And you are, I should note,
building these moments
with your children as well.
You got to go
to the beginning
of Taylor Swift's tour.
-Yes.
-Not a very easy ticket.
-No.
-Now, I know you've collaborated
with Taylor,
so you had an in.
-Yes. Yes.
I was very lucky to have an in,
and it was so amazing.
And Taylor now knows
the kids and wanted them there.
-And you had to obviously
choose your era.
What did you guys choose?
-We went all eras pretty much.
We went to the party store
and we honored
all the bedazzling
and all the colors and...
-And here are you
with your children.
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One and done.
You can tell you have
a film background, Laura,
because this is such
a well taken photo.
Just, you know...
you got perfect lighting.
This is a little bit
more professional.
There we go. There's the gang
there with Taylor.
-It was incredible.
-I mean, it's funny because,
I mean,
I think a lot of people
would imagine
that having Laura Dern
as a mom is a very cool thing.
But I imagine
when it's your own kids,
you have to go outside
the Laura Dern bubble
to really impress them.
I would hope
that Taylor delivered.
-She delivered. But it's --
I mean, guys, [laughs]
I've tried so hard for years
to be cool to them.
Music taste particularly.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Guys,
I'm playing you Nirvana.
You're nine years old.
This should be a great moment."
But it does turn around.
Like, once they're teenagers,
and you know, we're celebrating
loving the same artists.
-And do they remember
that you tried
when they were nine,
or did they completely forget?
Or do they come to you
and they're like, "Mom,
why didn't you tell me
about Nirvana?"
Do you just have to be like,
"I tried and you were dumb?"
-I mean, I will say,
I remember the moment
when their dad,
my ex, Ben Harper, said,
"Trust me, as a rock musician,
you think you're going
to be a cool dad.
They destroy me every day."
It's just -- You don't win.
-Well, there you go.
Well, you won a little there.
You take it
when you can get it.
And thanks so much
for being here.
What a delight to see you.
-I love it.
It's so good to see you.
-Laura Dern.
"Honey, Baby, Mine,"
available now
wherever you buy your books,
but please support local
and independent book stores.
Be right back
with Miranda Lambert.